Pulling into Brooklyn was a very important person, none other than Elvis Presley.
Private Presley, soldier nowadays in Uncle Sam's service.
The wonderful fans and an army of press men went on hand; this was indeed an occasion.
The rock and roll king was about to embark for foreign service: 18 months in Germany.
How the army would stand the impact of Mr. Presley was a big question months ago,...
...but not now as Elvis explains.
Elvis, since you've been in the army, have the boys given you kind of a rough time in the barracks...
...because of your past career, would you say?
No sir, I was very surprised.
I've never met a better group of boys in my life.
They probably would have.
If it had been like everybody thought,...
...I mean, everybody thought I wouldn't have to work...
...and I would be given special treatment in this and that.
But when they looked around and saw I was on KP...
...and I was pulling guard and everything just like they were,...
...well they figured, "Well, he's just like us."
When he is demobbed, Elvis hopes to develop his talent as a movie actor.
Meanwhile, it's the army for Elvis the Pelvis.